these guys have built up a massive  property portfolio how many houses do  you own uh just about 150 now 150 with a  property portfolio of about 20 million  pounds you guys have really really done  well however the interesting thing is  you sent your son 16 years old to my  property investors crash course what  happened well he got so inspired at 16  years old he bought his first house with  a joint venture partner how can you buy  a house at 16 years old i think he got  his company set it all up got the  knowledge and uh did it but did you give  him money no so you didn't give any  money 100 finance for the joint venture  party he found the house he found a  joint venture partner bought it best  piece of advice joe for someone who  wants to get started in property  get along to the crash course here we go  you heard it here first folks modern  guys massive respect absolutely killing  it and you can do the same thing too